[Music]
do you now or at any point in your life
like have have you felt like you've had
like a spiritual
spiritual connection or
you know i
when i put effort into it last year when
i had time i'm not a religious person um
i was at this place and they were
talking about spirituality and they're
like you know it doesn't you know it can
be
whatever i feel where they called it
your spiritual whatever and i use the
the universe you know and the reason is
is
i definitely didn't create it i don't
control it
i know it exists so okay the universe
will be my you know my my spirit uh
animal for for lack of a better term and
it it definitely did something and
and it was interesting because i
couldn't tell you
how or why but it i think what it did
was it it subconsciously
took a little bit of my need to control
away
um
and i i didn't realize how much that i
i had a
a problem with with control yeah but but
it's also it's like a shift from
it's a shift from controlling to to
behaving i don't know i i look at the
times in in my life that like trying to
connect to something bigger i've always
been really envious of people who who
have like a pretty rich or like at least
cogent spiritual life yeah i feel like
it like helps them you know like yeah
i'm the same way you've been in some in
incredibly
i want to use the word traumatic like
you've been in [ __ ] super super
[ __ ] high pressure situations were
you talking to anybody in those moments
was there anybody like i'm i'm i'm
honestly so glad you asked that question
uh because it's
again i i think an interesting story so
um and i don't know if i've ever told it
um
so when i got blown up i had an arterial
bleed so
um from my uh
ulna artery was
bleeding
and uh
so you know it gives you about
i mean it depends and again some doctors
can be like [ __ ] you you're wrong with
you know you have a couple minutes did
you know that
um
not at first at first i thought my arm
was blown off i i cause i could feel it
gone i know that sounds weird but it
felt not there
um and because it blew my nods off so i
couldn't see everything was dark in the
house there was gunfight going on i
couldn't hear anything
but when i eventually got outside of the
house there was a
like a [ __ ] porch light on and that
was the first time i looked at it and it
was [ __ ] hamburger me um and then it
was it was what it was hamburger meat i
mean it was just it was broken in so
many places that it it wasn't just like
twisted it was like
it was ma i don't know how they saved it
but it was mangled it it literally
looked
fake
um
but i noticed that
i was bleeding
pretty profusely
and then there was a wall like you know
and i just looked at i'm like well that
ain't [ __ ] happening you know like
i'm not getting over that um
and
i think i maybe at that point lost
consciousness for a minute or two i
remember
just plopping against the wall but
anyways i um
well at first i remember thinking okay
my arm is definitely gone it's [ __ ]
gone like
goodbye have a good one um i'm gonna be
an armless vet and i i just remember
this like whole process in my head of
thinking gotta be a one-armed and just
like flashes of vietnam veterans you
know we're in my head and and then i'm
like all right and i kind of accepted
that and then then i remember going whoa
wait a minute
you might die
and i was like oh [ __ ] yeah like i and
this within you know a couple seconds
sure i was like holy [ __ ] you might die
from this like
you gotta fix this and i'm like yeah you
don't want to die from this that'd be
[ __ ] stupid
and
then when um
uh one guy got to me uh which and this
is just [ __ ]
cosmic stardust the guy that comes and
puts the tourniquet on my arm
is the guy who i was with on that
mission in afghanistan when i was a
ranger
what are the odds of that
so
i'm there and i'm i'm laying there and
i'm i'm wait which which which guy from
from from remember when i said i worked
with the unit i wanted to go to and they
were selecting their own targets and
doing stuff in afghanistan yeah when i
was a ranger yeah that guy cut to i'm in
his unit now wow and he's the one who
put the tourniquet on my arm
wow the guy you're like i want to do
that yeah what are the odds you know
years later
um
and so i uh
but i'm i'm there and i'm and i and it
just kind of occurs to me that i you
know [ __ ] i i might die and and people
were working on on me but you know you
don't know
it's hard to gauge
you know uh
you know it's bad but like again you
don't and and are the guys that i mean
you were shot at oh there's a gunfight
going on in the house right so i mean
has that been dealt with yet or uh
i
no i think it was still going on they
were still fighting yeah it was a lot it
was a lot of guys um
but um
so anyways uh i'm laying there and i'm
like oh [ __ ] i i might die and then it
just kind of hits me i'm like
[ __ ]
i'm i might actually die
oh my god like
this is when religion comes and i'm like
i'm in this you know pain i'm in this
[ __ ] up situation i'm like kind of
excited like again human experi
experiment i'm like all right like come
on religion like you know where you go
where are you at where you at yeah i'm
like laying there and i'm like yeah yeah
like
all right you know how do i feel and i
just started like kind of going through
the process and
and i'm like
nope
still still nothing
like i and i legitimately thought i
could die and i just was like i just
i don't have it it just wasn't
it wasn't there and and
it's because i wasn't open to it
obviously you know i'm not a i'm not a
fool it was it was i was expecting
something to like hit me over the head
and you know and again it's the people
that are open to that concept and all
those things it comes to them the people
that it's just like i go to a i don't
believe in ghost and i go to a freaking
ghost house and i sleep there and um oh
shockingly i slept through the night and
had no [ __ ] problems weird right oh
they must have not come out that night
no it's that i don't [ __ ] care
you know and um
and so it's one of those things where
it kind of disappoint me to be perfectly
honest it kind of
and again it was my lack of you know but
i i was i was hoping that i was gonna
have some kind of like sense of
some kind of next step and i just
didn't
i just felt like i was just gonna die
right there in the [ __ ] mud and
a [ __ ] [ __ ] hole in solder city
shantytown like i just i didn't have a
good feeling about it i had like how
[ __ ] stupid would it be if i [ __ ]
died right here in the in the mud laying
down it just like kind of disgusted me
you know what i mean it didn't feel
honorable to you know what i mean it
didn't feel like i thought it should
feel it's like going out on the
battlefield you know like lieutenant dan
you know like
it just felt like if you experience
anything like that now do you feel like
it would be different i don't know if
that's an answerable question but you
know
i would hope
i i would hope um
i definitely have
a different spiritual belief um
now i the simple way to explain my
spirituality is i don't know what it is
but there's something bigger than me
yeah i know that yeah i don't know what
it is yeah it's a fact that i don't
[ __ ] know yeah but
it's proof that there's got to be
because i didn't [ __ ] create myself
so that's kind of where i'm at so i
would hope it would be different and and
um but yeah i've always been jealous of
people that are on that spiritual
wavelength to where it's just a real
connection right now you have so much to
say like right now you have so much to
do like you have so much work like you
have so much [ __ ] that you want to
do and accomplish and it just seems like
you know when i i don't know man it it
just seems to me so much of like your
psychology back then was like
[ __ ]
turning [ __ ] off yeah i was about
shutting everything off and now it's
about trying to open up and and
you know the other thing i mean i was
just a sad kid you know i was i was a
kid where they would
uh you know go like hey we're gonna go
toilet paper mr john old mr johnson's
house and you know i was like [ __ ]
seven eight nine and i'd be like
why i don't want to do that he'll have
to pick it up and they're like what the
[ __ ] are you talking you know i'm like
that would be sad watching old man john
and it just like
and they're like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know you know it just
discomfort his growth and i wanted that
disgusting is that bucket is that a
bucket that you feel like is filled with
like have you filled that bucket or is
that is that does that go forward it's a
struggle you know it's a strategy bro
it's a struggle that's a daily struggle
and
because
again i i can see where you know
there's a lot to um self-care and all
these different things
but
there hasn't been a time that i haven't
done something extremely
self-destructive
that i didn't learn something from and
and that i didn't
really gain from the experience and and
you know you're kind of
it's like balancing it's like is it
worth it you know and um
and i just have this fundamental need
sometimes and again going back to what i
said way earlier which is about
acceptance of self like i have finally
had to accept that at a certain level i
crave self-destruction
i just do and
i accept it
um
and i had to accept it because if i
pretended it wasn't there
it would it it would happen you know
without me really being a you know i
would just go into that mode so i just
like it look man again
you know i'm i'm super interested in
that and i think that's also not being
not sounding like a [ __ ] douche bag
but it's kind of like the artist's
journey too it's like i i believe
something you know we talked about him
earlier something shy and i kind of
argue about all the time like this this
need to like bleed out i don't know if
that's the same but can you give me an
example of like the last time or
something recently you felt like you've
done that was self-destructive
um
usually my self-destructive behavior was
with
was with women quite frankly uh i mean i
partied in vegas with strippers for like
two years straight that was [ __ ]
literally all i did you know um
and and that's a crazy lifestyle and and
it was a destructive lifestyle and
again it was
how much can i destroy myself
and still bring myself back
what level of destruction can i go to
and still come back from
and
i haven't found it
and i know what it is it's [ __ ] death
obviously
um
but how close could i get to that
it's a perverted sense of of
of self challenge challenge yeah
that cycle but is there a way you can
channel that into work and and that's
what i've been doing and that's what
i've been doing i've i've been much
better
like the last i i finally realized that
that about a year ago that that
self-destruction and that i was
attracted to
that destruction like that girl's
[ __ ] crazy well let me give her a
call let me tell her out you know like
hey those friends you shouldn't hang out
with them [ __ ] come on guys you know
like that was just what i was 100
the way it was and um
and and you know like a good example
would be again not that i know specifics
at all but commonly
mentioned about heath ledger and and his
process for the joker and all all these
things
it's
it's very it's just to me it's a similar
mentality of of self-destruction and and
the problem is society or people that
don't have that
it doesn't make sense so when you're you
know that way
uh in your normal life and you see
self-destructive behavior people are
like
you know in the military and the reason
i bring up the military is because it's
being
you know
they're they're just wrecking dudes
for getting duis getting you know do
what the [ __ ] are we doing speeding
miles an hour well because they were
trying to get some adrenaline yeah once
you've been at this level of adrenaline
and you go home like
once you've been shot at in close
proximity yeah well
you know how are you going to replicate
that hop you know buy a new motorcycle
and go 130 miles an hour you know it's
like okay uh man maybe i'll get the cops
to chase me [ __ ] it i don't care because
i'm trying to fee i'm you're chasing the
dragon of destruction no different than
chasing the dragon on a drug because
despite what most people say adrenaline
is an addictive [ __ ] drug absolutely
and once you've got it you're always
looking for it again
[Music]
snake